هذا لحظات مشاهدينا الكرام فقره وجه لوجهه
نخسيسها الانطلاق مناورات درع الصحراء
2002 الجزائريه الروسيه قرب الحدود
المغربيه لحظات والعود ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين الكرام
عند انطلاق مناورات درع الصحراء 2022
الجزائريه الروسيه في منطقه حماهير بولايه
بشار على مقروبه من الحدود المغربيه مع
ضيفيه مشاهدينا الكرام من الجزائر العاصمه
سيد احمد الخبير الامني والجيوستراتيجي
سيد احمد ميزابلانكا ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
على تربيه هذه الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا بكم تحيه طيبه اليكم والى
ضيفكم الكريم
مكاوي الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم ومرحبا وشكرا
جزيلا لك سيد عبد الرحمن مكاوي على تلبيه
هذه الدعم شكرا لك اخي حكيم وتحيه لضيفك
في الجزائر والى جميع المشاهدين
لكم الى المناورات عسكريه هي الاولى من
نوعها تحت عنوان عمال تكتيكيه للبحث عن
الارهابيين في الصحراء وتدبيرهم يتم
تنفيذها اذن في اطار برنامج التعاون
العسكري بين الجزائر وروسيا ما تعليقكما
على هذه المناره وهذا التمرين العسكريه
المشترك اثر عليك السؤال الاول سيد احمد
الخبير الامني استراتيجي مرحبا من جديد
اهلا وسهلا مره اخرى اعتقد بان هذه
المناورات درع الصحراء 2022 هي تندرج في
اطار التعاون العسكري والتوفيق بين
الجزائر وكذلك روسيا وفي اطار كذلك تبادل
الخبرات وكذلك تطوير ال ال القدرات في
اطار الحرب على الارهاب على كافه
المستويات ولننسى بان التخطيط لهذه
المناورات في اطار الاجتماع الاول كان في
شهر ابريل الماضي والذي كان في وضع مجموع
من السيناريوهات لهذه المناورات بالاضافه
كذلك الى الترتيبات اللوجستيه وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث على ان هذه المناورات هي تاتي
في اطار تعزيز القدورات وفي اطار كذلك
التعاطي مع مساله الظاهره الارهابيه
سياقاتها تطوراتها تفاعلاتها وكيفيه بلوره
المقاربات الامنيه الكفيله
بسياغه الادوات الامثل والمثلى في اطار
محاربه هذه الظاهره ولا ليس بان هذه
المناورات هي تجري ما بين همم
المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه لروسيا والقوات
العسكريه الجزائريه
روسيه الاولى من نوعها على الاراضي
الجزائريه للتدرب سيد عبد الرحمن مكاوي
على مواجهه التهديدات الارهابيه في بيئه
صحراويه ما تعليقك على هذه المناوره مرحبا
من جديد
كما اعلنتها وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
والسيده سكروا الناطقه الرسميه وهي البحث
عن الجماعات الارهابيه
وترصد تحركاتها وتدميرها والقضاء عليها
هذه وان هذه التداريب غير موجهه لاحد حسب
السيده سكروه فهذه الاهداف المعلنه ولكن
هناك
جاف غير معلنه خفيه وهي ان هذه وردت تجري
في اكبر قاعده صواريخ في المنطقه التي
بناها البر ليوتي سنه 1903 وتحولت سنه
1947 الى اكبر قاعده صواريخ فرنسيه حيث
انتجت فرنسا 17 نوع صاروخ باليستي في
منطقه حمه ولا هي كلمه مشتقه من الحماده
التي امتداد للهذاب العليا المغربيه وكذلك
واد جير الذي يجانبها فهذه القاعده قاعده
الصواريخ انطلقت منها اول صاروخ فضع فرنسي
سنه 1960 عريان الاول والذي نقل الى قويان
الفرنسيه بعد ذلك
فهذه همم
التحركات الروسيه فالروسيا يعلمون جيدا
اماكن الجماعات الارهابيه في المنطقه لان
لهم استخبارات عسكريه متطوره القرن وكذلك
الاف اس بي ولا لهم حضور عسكري من خلال
ميليشيا فكنير في شمال مالي فهم يعلمون
جيدا تحركات هذه الجماعات الارهابيه وكذلك
التنظيمات
الجريمه المنظمه المعبره للحدود
هذه الاهداف الخفيه وهي همم تدخل في اطار
الصفقه الضخمه التي ستبرمها الجزائر من
خلال زياره الرئيس التون الى
موسكوش 17 مليار دولار سوف تشتريها
الجزائر كسواريخ اس 400 وتسواريخ اسكندر
وكسواريخ كليبر وسوف تقيمها في منطقه
حماقير التي هي قاعده عسكريه لم ترجحها
فرنسا الى الجزائر الا سنه
1967 طيب سيد عبد الرحمن مكاوي حتى نبقى
دائما في اطار هذه الرسائل سواء كانت
المعلنه او الخفيه اعود اليك ضيف السيد
احمد ميزاب تتفاعل مع ما قاله ضيفي ايضا
شئت ولكن ما كان هذه المناورات لا فتى
الانتباه حتى ان صحيفه الجمال ديجيموس
الفرنسيه
ما الذي همم يفعله الجيشان الجزائري
والروسيه على الحدود المغربيه الاختيار
يقول البعض ليس بريئا وهنا اسال هل تمت
رسائل فعلا ضمنيه الى المغرب والى
الولايات المتحده التي اعترفت بمغربيه
الصحراء من خلال هذه المناوره هل ترد
الجزائر وهذا سؤال يطرحه كثيرون يطرحه
كثيرون اعلامناورات الاسد الافريقي الصيف
الماضي والتي اعتبرها البعض بدورها انذاك
حماله رسائل ضمنيه همم للجزاء السيد احمد
الميزان
لا خليني اقول اولا اعتقد اني بان السؤال
يجب ان ارد عليه بسؤال اخر وهو ما دخل
المغرب في الموضوع اعتقد بان المناورات
يوم مناورات ثنائيه بين الجزائر وروسيا
ولا دخل لاي طرف ثالث في هذه المساله
وليست مواجهه كذلك لطرف الاخر اذا ارادت
الجزائر ان تواجه اعتقد بانها تمتلك
الامكانات
الرسائل من ناحيه اخرى اعتقد بان الجزائر
لم تعلق على مناورات اسد افريقيا التي
قيلت عقود من الزمن وهي يتم اجرائها في
همم المغرب بالتالي نحن نتحدث على مساله
منفصله واعتقد بان من يحاول عبر وسائل
الاعلام
توظيف هذه المناورات بشكل مباشر او بشكل
غير مباشر في اطار اثاره المسائل الاخرى
جانبيه اعتقد بانه
يسير في الطريق الصحيح بقدر انه يسير في
مجال اخر هذه المناورات هي تاتي في اطار
التنسيق الثنائي بين الجزائر وروسيا في
اطار اهداف محدده واضحه بعيده كل البعد عن
الرسائل التي سوقت في وقت السابق واعتقد
كذلك بان الجزائر همم دوله مستقله دوله
كذلك ذات سياده لا اعتقد بانها تسير
بمخططات الماضي او بمخططات المستعمر وانما
هي كثيره
محدده وفقا كذلك تطوير قدراتها العسكريه
بما يستجيب لطبيعه التحولات سواء كان على
المستوى الاقليمي او حتى كذلك على المستوى
الدولي ويكفينا ان نتحدثه وفقا للتصنيفات
الدوليه المكان للجيش الجزائري سواء كان
على مستوى القاره الافريقيه او على
المستوى العربي او حتى كذلك الدول الدوليه
نحن نتحدث نحن نتحدث على مساله اساسيه وهو
ان الجيش الجزائري يسير في اطار تع قدره
وتطوير قدرته واعتقد بانه سبق هذه
المناورات التي التي تجرى درع الصحراء
مناورات اخرى تمت في عرض المتوسط في
الاسبوع الاخير من شهر اكتوبر الماضي ولا
اعتقد بانه ولا احد تحدث لماذا روسيا تجري
مناورات مع الجزائر
بالمتوسط وهي تعيش ازمه مع الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالتالي انه علينا ان نركز في
المضمون الحقيقي
لطبيقيه الذي
يواجه ايضا لتهديدات الامنيه القادمه من
منطقه الساحل التي تفرض الياقد المستمر
والحذر في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
بالامس مناوراته وتمرين تكتيكي ايضا همم
في الناحيه العسكريه الجزائريه الرابعه
قرب ليبيا ولا احد تحدث عن ايه رسائل
موجهه الى ليبيا هل تمت رسائل رومانيه
فعلا موجهه الى المغرب والى الولايات
المتحده من خلال هذا التمرين العسكري الرو
الجزائري الروسي المشترك في هذه المنطقه
التي تبعد نحو 80 كم تقريبا على الحدود
المغربيه اعرف هذه المنطقه جيدا لانني ابن
المنطقه فهي تبعد عن الحدود المغربيه ب 80
كلم فقط
وخاصه منطقه فيجيج وحسي بيضه فاعلم جيدا
ان هذه المنطقه حمره جير هناك قبائل
منقسما ما بين المغرب وحما جير كما قلت
امتداد للحماده المغربيه واللي هو تقير
الذي ياتي من المغرب
فالسؤال الذي تاتي هذه المناورات بعد
التحذيرات القويه التي قام بها 27 برلماني
امريكي للجزائر حول قضيه تمويل روسيا في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا من خلال همم هذه
الصفقات الضخمه ونحن نعلم انك 200 عنصر من
القوات الخاصه الروسيه لا
فقط 100 همم
الجزائريه
نعم يعني لا يمكن من نحي الفنيه التقنيه
العسكريه يعني السيطره على منطقه مساحتها
مرتين مساحات فرنسا همم نكون موضوعيين
ومنطقيين همم الروس يعلمون جيدا ما هي
التنظيمات الارهابيه الاسلاميه المزوره
وما هي التنظيمات الجريمه العابره للحدود
وان لهم تواجد كما قلت في شمال مالي وفي
الساحل وبالتالي فهم يعلمون فلهذا الغرض
منها كما قلت كما اشار اليها بعد خبراء
العسكريين في الولايات المتحده هو ان
تفعيل قاعده صواريخ اما جير التي هي قاعده
متطوره لاشارات المغرب ولا رد همم على
منارات
الامريكيه الاطلسيه ال المغربيه هناك
اشارات قويه من الولايات المتحده تحذيرات
لرئيس الاركان
الى المغرب ليست هناك اشارات ولكن الحدود
قريبه جدا وعندما نجري مناورات عسكريه
بالذخيره الحيه وبالسواريخ وبالطائرات
والحوامات
فقرب الحدود فهذا يعني استفزاز صعيد في
اطار التوتر الذي تعيشه العلاقات المغربيه
الجزائريه
مع الاسف الشديد ويجيبك على ذلك سيد احمد
زياره رئيس الروسي الذي من بوتين للجزائر
عام 2006 ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع
عن ذلك الميزانيه وزاره الدفاع الجزائريه
تتضاعفت ثلاث مرات تقريبا تكون صحيفه
في المئه من المعادلات العسكريه المستورده
عام 2017 هي من روسيا وهمم تم يطرح الان
هل اصبحت المنطقه المغاربيه صراحه ساح
التنافس روسي امريكي البعض يخشى حتى من
حرب بارده بانيابه او بالوكاله سيد ميزاب
تفضل
لا يعني خليني اقول انه من مضحك اولا ان
نتحدث عن الواقعيه
ونحنوا لا نسير نحو الطرح الواقعيه اولا
خليني اولا نقول بان الجزائر حدودها واضحه
وسيادتها كذلك واضحه واعتقد ذلك احتاج الى
ان يصير خارج الموضوع وانما علينا ان نكون
في صلب الموضوع المساله الثانيه يعني لو
انه قارن فقط مقارنه بسيطه وان كان سطحيه
يعني اسد افريقيا التي تشارك فيه 26 دوله
والمئات من الجنود وتستخدم فيه الذخيره
الحيه ويتم في اكثر من منطقه وعلى كذلك
الشريط الحدود وحتى كذلك في الاعراض ال-
ال- الصحراويه المحتله لم لم نتحدث ولم
نعلق على المساله ولم نعتبرها بانها
استفزاز او غير ذلك
في ايطار واضح وبعنوان كذلك واضح
وبمحدداته واضحه
ناتي للحديث لنقول بان هنالك استزاز اعتقد
بان المساله غير ذلك تماما من الجزائر لو
تريد ان توجه رسائل لا تحتاج الى ان تستند
على روسيا وان تاتي بروسيا من اجل تمرير
رسائل او غير ذلك من الامور النقطه الاخرى
الكل يعرف بان روسيا الشريك استراتيجي
للجزائر خاصه في المجال العسكري وان كان
الجزائر في السنوات الاخيره انتهت نهج
استراتيجي واضح وهو تنويع من شركائها في
مجال تعزيز قدراتها العسكريه المساله
الاخرى كذلك تنافس الامريكي الروسي ليس
محصور بين المغرب والجزائر في قدرنا انه
موجود في الساحه الافريقيه بل تعني اقول
باننا نتحدث اليوم
في في المنطقه المغاربيه
في هذه الاونه الاخيره حتى
الغزو الروسي له اوكرانيا خليني خلينا
نروح لك مباشره الى صلب الموضوع اذا كان
نحن نفعل التهديد او نتحدث على تصعيد بل
نتحدث على وجود الكيان الصهيوني اليوم في
قلب المنطقه والذي اصبحت تهديد الامن
القومي المغاربي بشكل عام نحن نتحدث عن
اتفاقيه امنيه نتحدث على وجود عسكري نتحدث
على تجهيزات تتحدث على اشياء متعدده اعتقد
بان هذا قد يكون جوهر للحديث والنقاش اذا
اردنا ان نتحدث على مساله التصعيد على
مساله وغير ذلك
همم عليها همم تحديدا
هذا هو هذا هو هذا هو هذا هو بيتابعه
الحال همم نعم روسي للجزائر في مقابل دعم
امريكي
للمغرب وكثيرون يسالونها اليوم هل اصبح
هذه المنطقه المغربيه ساحه تنافس امريكيه
روسيه او تشهد حتى حربا بارده كما وصفت
بالوكاله السيد عبد الرحمن
الولايات المتحده منذ عهد ترامب اعترفت
بمغربيه الصحراء
وبيحل حكم الذاتي
للاقاليم الجنوبيه المغربيه حتى الاتحاد
حتى روسيا الان امتنعت في مجلس الامن همم
يعني همم
للتصويت ضد المشروع همم الاميه هناك
علاقات ممتازه تجمع همم
روسيا مع المغرب سواء على المستوى
الاقتصادي او المستوى الاجتماعي او عن
المستوى السياحي والمستوى الفلاحي
كما قال الرئيس بومدين انا ذاك همم
الجزائر لها جيبوها في اليسار ولها عقلها
في اليمين في فرنسا وفي الولايات المتحده
فلا المغرب له علاقه ممتازه مع الصين
الشعبيه وكذلك مع روسيا فيما يخص مغربيه
الصحراء فالقضيه قد حسمت على مستوى المجلس
مجلس الامن الدولي وهناك مشروع ديميستورا
لحل حاله الموضوع من خلال طاولات مستوي
رايج يجمعوا فيها جميع الاطراف
لعل هذه النزاع لان هذه النزاه قال اما ده
على حساب تنميه هذه
اصبحت المنطقه المغاربيه ساحت صراع همم ما
بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا على خلفيه
حتى ااه الحرف اوكرانيا هذا هو سؤال همم
الحرب في اوكرانيا الان همم الولايات
المتحده وخاصه الكونغرس الامريكي
والجنه الاستخبارات تحذر الجزائر
ما خبت شمول الحرب الاوكرانيه من خلال هذه
الصفقات الضخمه 17 مليار دولار من اسلحه
للجزائر همم
الكونغرس الامريكي ويجلس الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تحذر الجزائر وقد دعت سفيره
الولايات المتحده في الجزائر يعني رئيس
الاركان من مغابه يعني الاستيقاظ مع روسيا
في حربها همم ضد اوكرانيا وكذلك الحلف
الاطلسي ارسل المدير الشؤون العسكريه الى
رئيس الاركان الى غير هناك تحذيرات قويه
للجزائر الا ان الجزائر لها خطابين
متناقدين على المستوى الداخلي هناك شراكه
استراتيجيه مع روسيا ونحنوا القوه
الاقليميه وعلى المستوى الخارجي مع همم
الاطلسي وكذلك الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
فاننا سوف اعاده التفكير في علاقتنا مع
روسيا فهناك خطابات
همم قد يعاقب على ذلك ضيف السيد احمد
الميزاب لديه دقيقتان فقط دقيقه لك سيد
احمد ميزاب ودقيقه للسيد عبد الرحمن
المكاوي سؤالي الان هذا تنافس الجزائري
المغربي كما يوصف الى اين سيقود البلدين
هل فوت الطرفان فرصه ذهبيه في تسويه
خلافاتهم خلال القمه العربيه في الجزائر
وهل يمكن وهذا هو ال- ال- المهم والاساس
هل يمكن تدارك ذلك بين البلدين سيد ميزات
دقيقه واحده لو سمحت
ما بين البلدين ان هناك مجموعه من الفوارق
التي تدفع الى ذلك لكن من ناحيه اخرى
اعتقد بان الجزائر موقعها واضح احيانا
الازمه الاخرانيه وهو الموقف الذي كذلك تم
اتخاذه في اطار القمه العربيه التي احتضنت
الجزائر وهو موقف الحياد الايجابي بمعنى
انه لا يمكن همم في همم اطار اي طرف من
الاطراف النزاع والسراع وبالتالي الجزائر
تحافظ على ذات العلاقات مع روسيا وهي
معلنه وليست مخفيه وفي ذات سياق كذلك هناك
مجموعه من الاتفاقات مع عديد من دول
الاوروبيه في اطار التزويد بالطاقه في
اطار الازمه المتناميه في المنطقه التي
اهل الجزائر بان يكون شريك استراتيجي
للدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا ما ذكر في
احد الدراسات التي تقريبا منذ اقل من يوم
في همم احد المجلات العلميه الامريكيه ومن
ناحيه اخرى كذلك اعتقد باننا اليوم نحن
نتحدث على ان الجزائر تلعب دور الاخباريه
واساسي
اعترفين فرصه ذهبيه
او لم تفوت الفرصه ومن ناحيه ثانيه كذلك
في ظل الممارسات المستمره في اطار استهداف
الجزائر في اطار كذلك امل وسياده الجزائر
اعتقد بانه لا يتوفر المناخه في تسويه هذه
الازواج
في هذه المرحله للتواصل لهذا الحل وراء
بسضع بين البلدين والتسامح
لان العقيده العسكريه الجزائريه منذ 1962
منذ اتفاقيات ايفيا والاستفتاء في الجزائر
حول استقلال الجزائر بنيت على الاعداء
الوهميه للمغرب وفرنسا واللي طرف ثالث همم
العقيده العسكريه بنيه على العدو
الكلاسيكي كما
يرددها دائما
ايجابيه في الاونه الاخيره كانت حتى من
الطرفين ولكنها لم ترى النور
عبد الحفيظ بوصوف منذ 1962 لا زالت قائمه
الى الان فلا الجزائر العامل في الارهاب
في الداخل
وملف المغرب في
الخارجيه
الاخيره ولكن لم نصل الى المطلوب هذا هو
الملك جلاله الملك محمد السادس يعني في
خطابات متعدده يعني اشار الى ضروره الحوار
مع الجزائر وان اي شر لم لم ياتي من
المغرب تجاه الجزائر فايادي الممدوده مده
كثيرا الان الشعب المغربي يضغط
لحسم هذا الموضوع نهائي
ونتمنى ان الشعب الجزائري الذي هو اخوه
ولنا ونحن نكن لهم كل الاحترام وكل
التقدير
يغيرون هذه الواقع هذه العقيده همم التي
اصبحت اسطوانه مشروخه
يطالبون ايضا بنفسه شيء على كل كل ما
نرجوها هذه الخلافات في اقرب همم ممكن لان
تبيعاتها خطيره وسلبيها للغايه على
المنطقه على كل شعوب المنطقه همم روماتها
كلها شكرا جزيل لكما على هذه الحلقه ولا
تربيه الدعوه من الجزائر العاصمه سيد احمد
بن زياد الخبير الامن والاستراتيجي ستكون
لنا موعد اخرى سيد احمد همم حتما في
الاستديو سيد عبد الرحمن المكاوي الخبير
في شؤون الامنيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا
لنا مواعيد اخرى ايضا شكرا جزيلا لكم ما
كنتما معنا في فقره وجهها